hey so sorry for little dastan but again
do you want to sew first types of need
to be the chair for that afternoon so
it's my pleasure to introduce a
Lafayette from UT Austin talking about
decoding and modeling brings navigation
okay thank you thanks very much it's a
pleasure to be here Fritz and Terry
thanks for the invitation I guess I've
been here and out for a while and I
guess thank you also to the sinus
Institute and to all the concomitant
organizational effort on the part of
Bruno and others who've organized this
bigger program it's just been a joy and
a pleasure to actually spend a month and
a half here so far I think it's set up
beautifully it's just a lovely place for
interaction so um I hope we have more
neuroscience programs here in the future
all right so I want to tell you a little
bit today about some of our recent work
on two different projects really but
both of them sort of have as a common
theme something you know and efforts of
the nexus of neuroscience and machine
learning okay and so what I want to talk
about is two specific challenges that
we've been thinking about recently from
neuroscience and so one the first one
that I'll tell you about is about the
problem of unsupervised discovery by us
as scientists okay of latent variables
that the brain is representing and
they're real time dynamics right so the
Blayne brain is representing something
we want to discover what it is the
second problem is that of the discovery
of latent variables by the brain about
variables out there in the world that
are important for it to perform
computations on and manipulate in real
time to you know do things that the
brain needs to do okay and so those are
sort of the two parts that I'm going to
be talking about so okay so the first
problem is the problem of extracting
latent variables with non-trivial
topological structure encoded in
cognitive circuits and so what I'm going
to try to tell you about is a problem in
a challenge of unsupervised decoding
from neural data and I think clay is
going to be talking about some pretty
similar things if I'm right and judging
by the abstract but you can tell me if
I'm wrong but so the problem is the
following okay so in general we've got
you know
a brain right and what we like to do is
neuroscientists as we like to think or
pretend or in many cases sometimes you
know to lowest order actually succeed in
you know driving the brain with certain
stimuli okay and then we like to record
what's going on in the brain areas and
then try to recover from the recordings
the value of the stimulus that was
presented okay like that's what we've
done in a lot of sensory neuroscience a
lot of motor neuroscience for a while
right but often the case that we don't
know what variable is encoded in the
brain for example even if you're trying
to control some sensory inputs we may
not have total control of the whole
sensory world okay and moreover there
are internal states that the brain has
right it's generating its own states and
you know we may not know or have control
over those states okay and so the point
is also in areas that are more cognitive
areas for the remove from the sensory
and motor peripheries this problem is is
exacerbated right like it's it's bit
it's you know it's doing some higher
order processing so very often I would
argue that one doesn't know what's going
on in there um this the same problem
also arises in different behavioral
states like for example even in a
circuit that's doing something that we
feel we can characterize pretty well say
low-level visual cortex or the retina or
something else in in waking it could be
that the circuits you know in a
different than dynamical regime doing
something different during other states
like sleep right and so what we want to
do is ideally be able to take neural
data like a time series of just spikes
from a bunch of neurons simultaneously
recorded and be able to say something
about the encoded variable okay that's
kind of the problem right and so the
question is if we don't know what
variable is represented in the circuit
response what can we learn about it from
the from from the time series data just
spiking alone no external variable okay
so what's the current approach the
current approach is that we know or
control the independent variable right
and then we characterize the responses
of neurons by regression on to those
independent variables right you so
usually you just take the spikes regress
them on to the this variable that we're
controlling and then you know
characterize them by like constructing
things like tuning curves right which is
the mean respond
to the neuron to that individually
externally control variable or by you
know saying something about the para
values relationships within neurons like
the correlations etc okay and then the
other thing that we do is we assume that
the same characterization applies in
different behavioral States so instead
what we'll do today is we considered
like I said just in the last slide that
the independent variable is unknown okay
and then we'll also you know instead of
doing things paralyzed or and we'll sell
myself the hope is to understand
something about the encoded variable
from the full high dimensional response
of the neurons right so it's a neural
you know large number of neurons in a
circuit and we want to try to
characterize something about the
structure of where these responses live
in the high dimensional space state
space of total responses okay and so
this is so so the idea is to
characterize the topology and structure
the full population response you know or
the manifold of you know States and then
decode the states and the dynamics on
the manifold itself okay so this
manifold kind of approach is something
that's really theoretically motivated
from like a long line of theoretical
work on trying to understand dynamics in
neural circuits so some of these works
on you know understanding circuit
responses of sort of like emergent
phenomena from you know interacting
populations of neurons and then thinking
about you know sort of the the allowed
States on the manifold in high
dimensional state space were introduced
by Amaury in 77 hopfield you know these
are tons of work on this including you
know work ok so these were kind of more
theoretical works and then more recently
there was you know thinking about
dynamics and you know manifolds and in
state space by in the experimental
context by G Lorentz group and then also
by David over here he's done beautiful
work on you know looking at the motor
system using this manifold approach and
you know so the shenoy lab David and
various others in the motor context
right so so sort of you know this is a
tradition that you know is being
therefore in theory it's it's been you
know very interesting in in its
application to data analysis and so
we're just going to pursue things in the
same direction ok so so this is going to
be a philosophy over here
and then finally instead of assuming the
same characterization applies in
different behavioral states we get to
just three examine the manifold
structure in one state and then the next
state in the next state and therefore
you know without first assuming that the
states remain the same and then decoding
them we're going to first examine
whether or not states remain the same in
circuits across sleep and waking and
then we can say something about the
dynamics in them so that's the idea and
the idea is also that you know all of
this since we're not gonna explicitly
assume that we have knowledge of the of
the external variable these are going to
be fully unsupervised or blind methods
and moreover these methods require no
kind of trial structure averaging right
so one doesn't need to you know because
we're not going to use any averages we
don't have to you know ask our
experimental collaborators to build
trials and blocks and then do a lot of
math so it's all single trial and with
no trial structure okay so what's the
method so the method is the following so
we gave it a name spud spine
parameterization based on supervised
decoding and conceptually that this is
what we do these are the steps okay so
take the take the snapshot of activity
of all the neurons at one moment in time
and that's the point and if they're in
neurons it's a point in an n-dimensional
space so for example that point okay so
that's one snapshot of the spike current
of all the neurons in that time bin and
then you know for different for
different times the response looks like
you know a different point and the idea
is if that if the system the circuit is
encoding some low dimensional variable
okay some variable that matters that's
low dimensional it's an N continuous
then it's going to form some kind of a
low dimensional continuous manifold okay
of whatever dimension and whatever
topology and so the next step is then to
characterize the topology of the
manifold okay so to understand does this
manifold have holes in it does it have
you know tools in it does it have is a
plat etc right so we do topological
characterization using topological data
analysis methods very briefly these
methods that these are methods from
persistent homology and the idea is just
that supportive guide you know some data
points over here this is schematic what
you do is you you okay so so we can
systematically blow up these data points
to sort of blur them systematically so
we construct you know balls of different
radii around the data points and then
ask about connected structures okay
these so-called simplistic complexes
within within within within the data so
here is a ring that emerges okay at this
resolution and then when you increase
the ball radius you can see that now
there are two two rings okay
independently they're emerging here so
rings in in in topology are
characterized by a Betty one number and
so this orange ring appears here this
radius okay so this is something called
a Betty barcode so we've got you know
the existence of the Betty one number
versus the radius of blur for the data
points and at this radius of blur say to
this orange ring appears it persists at
this radius and then by the time the
radii are increased of the balls that
you can see that that first hole is
filled in so then this feature this ring
feature disappears but then this yellow
feature has appeared here in the
meantime and then this continues for a
few different radii until once the balls
get big enough and it's all one compact
object right so so then so then that
number terminates to so if there's a
feature in the data that persists over
many different radii that's called like
you know persistent feature and that's
the measure in topological data analysis
of the robustness of a feature of this
existence okay so so that you know doing
this for like different Betty numbers
helps to characterize what is the
topological structure of the manifold
okay mmm the other thing when we also
uses local dimensionality estimation so
locally in a manifold what is the local
dimension of it and so they're different
dimensionality estimation techniques
which we can bring to bear in the
problem including like this thing called
correlation dimension where you take a
ball and increase the radius around it
and ask how does the number of data
points within that ball grow is the
radius increases right so if you have a
straight line and you increase the ball
radius then the number of points
enclosed within the ball should grow
linearly if it's if it's a sheet like
locally two-dimensional it should grow
quadratically etc right so so that gives
you some estimate of local dimension
okay and so having now characterized
something about manifold it's deployed
units you know local dimensionality we
can then go ahead and decide what what
is the matter flow structure and so we
can then the next step that we do is fit
a spline through the manifold okay of
matching topology and dimension yeah
there's a
your friends are to the localization
yeah I mean okay so I okay so first of
all I should point out that really this
local dimensionality reduction is a bit
of its ill-posed in the same sense that
clustering is imposed right because all
of this you know some neural data are
noisy so I should point out that these
methods tend to work very well for for
relatively low noise datasets for you
know for noisy data you know this this
persistence of some measure and topology
for you know the existence of a feature
and you know even in the presence of
noise but really you could imagine that
there is a ring feature that just looks
filled in because of noise in the data
right and so and then it's gonna be
filled in I mean it's it's even even
though this is really a ring that
generated it okay and so like I like to
say that you know we don't have a
statistical setting in which to do tape
topological data analysis it's really a
non statistical method and then
similarly with this correlation to
mention you know in some cases I like to
say that it's sort of an intent it tends
to be an overestimate of the dimension
because if you've got really something
that's essentially two-dimensional but
then you're sampling it with noise then
you know it's going to look you know
locally and dimensional because really
the data are live in and dimension so
you've got this fluff and dimensional
fluff around the two dimensional
manifold and so but then the idea is you
know once you you know so you start out
so for example and this is a line or is
it row right so it's it's not just noise
the question is is this really a line or
is this really a thinner two dimensional
ribbon right I don't know I mean it kind
of depends on what scale you care about
right so all we can say is that you know
at the scale this is the size this much
dimension and yeah and we're not doing
any like interaction we're not doing
like something iterative over here and
so yeah so do we just do this on the raw
data or do you somehow renormalize oh
this can all be done in principle this
should all be done on the raw data okay
what we do in the middle and it's only
purely because of signal-to-noise ratio
constraints you can do a division ality
reduction step where you just instead of
taking the manifold in n dimensional
space you consider it in some K
dimensional space where K is still much
bigger than the manifold dimension okay
but it's just because you know the
number of cells that we're talking about
is just you know ten
the SNR is actually you know relatively
it's not as high as it could be if we
had you know a hundred hundreds of cells
or thousands of cells SNR would be much
better we could just do it in the full
high dimensional space so really any
intermediate dimensionality reduction is
just for noise reduction just for SNR
and because the idea is you know if you
yeah okay so I'm sorry we only have well
I mean meaning it's not awesome party we
don't do any smoothing irregular right
we do binning which is like that's the
only form of regularization we do so we
take yeah okay you're right it's a lot
it's a lot okay so but so so the thing
is like we take this we take this pi
times but then we slice it into time
bins and the time bidding is also
governed by our snr all right in ideally
you always want to go to the smallest
time bin that you can but by shrinking
it you get less elsinore but you also
compromise temporal resolution so our
goal is you know but I'm going to show
you the test right you're always if
you're using a new method you're always
doing it at the limit of when the method
can be applied and so that's where we
are right now but I'm confident and once
we have you know I'll show you the data
you can look at it but once we get you
know like three times the number of data
I think our snr is going to be really
good for the same dimension a linear
manifold but of course it's questions
about how that scales with manifold
dimension you know manifold dimension
skills like you know if it goes up if
you have deep sub M is the manifold
dimension then of course the number of
data points you need but any method is
going to be e to the D to the N right to
sample the the manifold so I don't think
that's a problem with our method that's
just a that's the product that's just
like the generic problem of
understanding structure writers within
the resolution of the noise cloud so and
I would like to point out and I will I
will point out that actually you know
okay let me finish then I finish telling
you about the method I'll tell you about
how the number of parameters is
independent of the of the types of the
length of the time series and
independent of the number of neurons so
that means that the the number of
parameters independent number of neurons
here's SNR just grows as you have more
neurons so that's a nice feature I don't
know the order so I'm just gonna
randomly call people I guess I'd rate
since you're in the back I'll call you
so so
record all neurons it might be involved
in the phenomenon in the dynamics ie the
space you're looking at yeah the true
space yeah this is some sample of the
space that's right you mean you hope you
hope that in some sense the neurons are
kind of you know have a some
homogeneously distributed at least role
in the circuit if they're two circuits
that are doing different things and only
sample from one circuit then of course I
won't know where the other circuits
doing right so you kind of hope that you
know and there's also my talking's
embedding theorem we know that basically
there's a system that's full dynamical
system then you know you should be able
to even just take you know one
observation you should be able to only
look at one or two neurons than just
sample whole space so it's really about
like all the neurons this is a good mix
set of the neurons participating please
so so these the X's would be something
like firing rates say these acts these
are exactly this is this a spike count
in neuron ones by Counting neuron 2 etc
opticians n-dimensional
my question is so I can imagine how all
of the actual combinations you get from
your population lie on this manifold but
that doesn't apply that as the system
involves it moves smoothly
it could be zipping around right it
means very good yeah yeah if I think
about neurons you know one yarn will
stop firing nothing will fire and that
might shoot you over to some other part
of it is there some are you you're
asking for a stronger form of coding
where there's actually information in
the continuity of this thing or could
you and is there do you have particular
methods that pull that out as opposed to
just a subspace but which could be
randomly sort of moved around okay those
are all great questions so um okay so
one thing so one is that first of all
you know if we think that there's some
you know smooth variable in the world
through which the animal is moving then
presumably right like if for example
with the spatial variable or some other
variable like usually you move through
in a continuous way now it's true that
one yarn can turn on another one can
turn off but you know hopefully they're
overlapping neurons with some
tuning so that you know they can kind of
go down smoothly enough and if we have
enough neurons then our time bin will
shrink so we have better sampling
resolution in time so we can see that
smooth evolution and finally it's true
that you know you know maybe you could I
could certainly conceive of something
where an animal's just thinking about
some variable and maybe jumping from one
point to the next in a very
discontinuous way and I'll say actually
our method one thing that we're not
exploiting which we could is the real
temporal aspect of the of the data so it
David tanks group at the moment is doing
something conceptually identical to what
we're doing but but in terms of
implementation or the algorithms they're
using something different they're not
they're actually using explicitly the
time series of transitions between
adjacent points in time and so they
sedate so they're actually exploiting
that temporal structure we're not so you
know if it's not temporally continuous
then that's an assumption that would
break down in that case in our case we
didn't exploit it but but they would do
better I mean they would probably
extract more information by using the
time series which we're not doing but
then all the same time we won't pay the
price for that if that assumption is
violated
so I'll just say that yeah I think those
are all great police those could be a
case in point right away you know if you
at least if you have a local
representation where these places in
place you might use all of those oh yeah
yeah so I should say one more thing okay
so the data set I'll show you is a
spatial firing cell and indeed the the
evolution of the trajectory is extremely
nonlinear okay so it's like this very
narrow curve exactly for the reason that
you said so maybe you're probably
jumping ahead I'll come back why do I
come back to that and I'll actually
mention that point there okay there is
so much are there any other questions or
should I continue yeah to measure like
diffusion that was my nickel burning
what did you think it consistent results
that's a good question we haven't tried
the diffusion maps yeah so yes there are
and like self-organizing maps and other
things yeah there's many methods and
this method that I measured by day I
mentioned by David tanks group and I
heard just last week that there's a
similar conceptual approach by Ziv and
his colleagues yani reserve and they're
also doing manifold decoding and they
have yet another complimentary approach
and I bet Clavin telling us about yet
another one so so they're a bunch of so
these
all it conceptually the same idea right
there's like some low dimensional
manifold in the state space
let's parameterize it and then let's
extract the information from it yeah it
seems like oh I'm sorry and I should
mention David David has work I guess are
you going to talk about that yeah
oh fads yeah so David yeah we'll be
talking also about another method so
yeah it seems like the dimensionality of
the manifold is going to change simply
by adding cells to the set to the sample
that you're looking at because because
every random walk is recurrent on a
finite space and you're going to be
filling in more and more of these cells
you're going to have more but you're
assuming so that's so that it's okay so
this there's a key assumption here right
our assumption is that the circuit as a
population is encoding some low
dimensional variable right and in this
in within that framework in fact the
dimensionality the manifold reflects the
encoded variable not the states of
independently evolving neural responses
which are uncoupled from one another
because then yeah that would be dense
right in the space so so that's the
point right here as you add neurons to
your sample you're you're embedding
space grows right with the number of
neurons it's our you know it's
n-dimensional space but the point is the
manifold it really reflects the variable
that's being encoded something about the
world that you care about and and that's
what and that's you know something
that's not going to change your sample
as it grows bigger you're just snr in
understanding what that is is going to
improve for example you so show open
paths there which eventually must
intersect yeah yeah I'm just showing you
a segment that's right so yeah so okay
yeah I'm just showing you just this is
all a schematic so it's just just to
show you okay so so let me just complete
the method and then we'll go to the
actual data so then we can talk about
what that looks like okay so what we do
is then once we've got some some
estimate of the topology and the local
dimensionality of the manifold we can
then you know get a spline of matching
demand or you know dimensionality in
topology and then fit it to the manifold
and now the important step is that we
get a local coordinate system
representation now of the data by just
permit rising along the spline okay so
like we go you know we have a sign them
coordinate alpha as we move along the
spline and then you know that's our
that's gonna be our decoded estimate of
the variable so basically you know there
are also goo
all dimensionality reduction methods
where you you know right locally linear
embedding and ISO map etc and these
methods you know though provide a global
coordinate system for your data right by
doing some nonlinear embeddings this is
by contrast a local coordinate system
and that's really important when you
have some non-trivial topology because
if you've got a ring the lowest
dimension in which you can embed a ring
is two dimensions so like these global
dimension reduction reduction methods
will give you two dimensional
coordinates right to coordinate system
representations here we need something
in this case like a one dimensional
coordinate right so this this method
will allow you to do that okay finally
the decoding step is now given any point
you can then project it on to the spline
the parameter I supply and read off the
value of the parameter at that point and
that gives you your instantaneous
readout for the latent variable okay so
that's just philosophically that's it
okay so oh yeah a number of parameters
are you know de is like some
intermediate this okay K is the number
of you know anchors in the spline and
then de is the you know embedding
dimension of the space in which you do
all of this which could be the full data
dimensional space or it could be or
rather it could be some you know others
dimensionality which is much bigger than
the manifold dimension but much smaller
than the number of neurons for noise
reduction so that's just how many
parameters you need and it can be
completely independent of T and n right
so you just fix pick some fixed
dimension and then as you increase T or
you increase n in either case your
signal-to-noise ratio should go up or T
is the time over which you collect
points and then n is the number of
points okay so here's our data set so
our data set is um time series data from
the head Direction Circuit of mammals
okay and from the thalamic region so
from a DN or thalamus actually this this
data I'm showing you is actually
collected from two different areas post
cibecue limb which is hippocampal
capital area and then adn which is at
the lamech area okay so we've just Co
invented all of that data and what you
can see is you can see with this
topological data analysis is a really
really persistent very one feature that
you know suggests that there's a ring
structure and the data and in fact
because this data is so low dimensional
we can actually construct a linear
embedding
I'm gonna knock a nonlinear low
dimensional embedding of the data
into three-dimensional space and I'm
just showing you two-dimensional
projection of that and you can see this
beautiful cloud of points that's the
ring okay so first of all I'd like you
to just pause and see that you know this
is a this is a ring visualization of the
Ring Network of the head direction
network in the brain right which thing
this thing here there here yeah this is
not this is just noise it really is not
about you can look at that you can look
at the whole barcode right this is just
one projection if you look this is this
is a very nonlinear okay so so now
getting to David's point right so so
this ring is actually it's a
one-dimensional ring but it's extremely
nonlinear and in fact there isn't a good
there's not a low dimensional linear
projection of this ring so basically if
used linear methods it there's no good
low dimensional projection of it because
basically if you think about these cells
these head Direction cells have these
narrow tuning curves so basically as you
move around an angle then one cell turns
on turns off the other cell turns on
turns off so in the state space axis
it's like you're basically going up one
axis coming down it going up the other
axis it's really pointy it's like a
pointy flower that goes with petals
around each axis okay so so really it's
like it's like a it's like a
one-dimensional line that occupies
almost and you know all n dimensions it
goes through all of them and so it's not
in your knitting yeah I'm sorry
oh okay so great question so this is an
awake Mouse that's running around just
foraging in the standard spatial tasks
it's running around and I think a square
box looking for food like chocolate food
pellets or something
what's not but it's not what this is not
two dimensional to one dimensional first
of all and secondly it's not running in
a circle it's running you know with
varying speeds and varying directions
all over 2d space and I'll also show you
well okay well I mean okay look you
could say that the head directions so I
guess what you're saying is okay there's
many things that you could be saying one
thing that you could be saying is that
okay first of all if we didn't know
these were head Direction cells you
there's no reason you should expect them
to have any structure like this right if
you recorded play cells they would not
be looking like this if I recorded v1
neurons and I plotted this manifold it
would not look like this
if I plotted any cell network in the
brain it wouldn't look like this okay
even in this task okay now for it so
okay so I think it is remarkable that it
looks like this secondly I think maybe
you're saying given that it's the head
directions circuit I'm not surprised
that it looks like this and I would only
be surprised if you made it do stuff in
3 or 4 D but the point is it is right
and conceptually right again it's not
like all these cognitive variables it
could be thinking about its 2d space
this is showing you it doesn't it's not
representing 2d position right I mean
the question is what is this other
variable you would like it to explore to
you know to rule out that has another
dimensional response right so first of
all the topological data analysis tells
you it's a ring right not it it does
it's not a torus it's some information
what when you know other know great let
graph on the left with a little spike
out there is this is the ring feature
and there are no other ring features and
we've looked at the Betty to number
there's no other important Betty to
numbers so we've done the topological
characterization which says it's a ring
this is just for your viewing pleasure
nothing else it's because we can only
see things in 2d okay we are just very
limited that way if I could I would get
you well I could have made the movie and
I could have shown you the 3d movie it's
not and actually if you predict protect
the 3d sphere on to 2d it's not gonna
look like a ring it's gonna look like a
disc no but this has not been here
there's nothing here like right this is
all the data it's not that it's dense on
the ring and you know something less
dense in the center didn't show us that
it has anything to do with her direction
yeah okay so okay so let's let's let's
go there right so okay great oh no I had
a medical ID I was just I just want to
strength your point that the question is
more you're giving a data matrix
potentially very high dimensional what
could you extract from that that's it
presumably that if you would do what
everybody does is just principal
component analysis and choose the first
two principal components then it
wouldn't look like that that's right it
wouldn't this is really just intrinsic
information extracted from the data
matrix and this persistence diagram
shows you that you have this one like if
you just look at one dimensional
information when you have this
persistent ring and this is just a bit
of visualization yeah yeah it's just for
your viewing pleasure this is not
analysis here okay this is just to show
you guys and this is the analysis and
then the spline okay so we finished
lying to this manifold okay so we've
determined that it's you know locally
low dimensional we've determined that
it's got like this one single ring
feature we fit a ring to it and then we
parameterize along this ring okay and so
okay so we so we do that and then let's
look at what we can do with that okay so
we decode now so we can do unsupervised
decoding okay so first of all now we've
colorized this all the data points
according to this latent variable okay
and so and on the right side what you'll
see is actually the
same data points now colorized by
actually measured head Direction okay
and what your easier is that it can I
just get to in just a moment so when we
look at the measured head direction and
this is the completely unsupervised
decoding okay and all we've done is of
course we can be because the origin and
the direction of movement arbitrary we
allow those two to match and then you
can see the coloring is almost identical
except for like a few points in the
center to show you that I'm not cheating
their coloring is slightly different
there okay so yeah what is the
correction of the head with respect to
like this some external reference frame
with which they measure they have some
arbitrary origin and that's why the
origin is arbitrating also the direction
in which you define the increase in
angle is arbitrary right so we just can
match those but everything else is
completely it's all it is all
unsupervised and just for comparing the
two pictures again we just do the
rotation so this is no are free to look
up and down in fact they often put their
head up on the you know on the wall like
they'll put their head up like this and
do that but the ring then like I
understand it if you look like like one
dimensional yeah I don't know what
should be right again we're not doing
this normatively this because this is
not you know what is the head right this
does not talk about what the head
rection circuit should be like right all
I'm doing is I'm starting with a problem
of given a data matrix what can we say
about the structure and what can we say
about what the structure represents the
world that's it right I'm not making a
statement about what it should do or
anything else right so so we're just
going to go from there so okay so
alright so now now I've shown you the
coloring let's look a little bit more
quantitatively so in the blue curve here
oops sorry
in the blue curve here the blue curve is
the is the latent variable right so the
completely unsupervised
you know decoded estimate of this latent
variable black is the measured head
direction and you can see that these
actually match exceedingly well okay and
this oh yeah so the high direction here
the definition oh maybe that's what you
were getting at the the definition of
measured head Direction is just the 2d
is is the is just the direction
as a compass direction with respect to
some arbitrary reference right they put
an LED on the head and then they yeah
and then they just expect you from that
direction is it pointed into D that's it
exactly so there's computed 2d
projection and then and then get that
right so okay that's it and then and
then we do another estimate which is
based on like fully supervised decoding
reconstruction and curves between the
neural activity and the measured head
direction and then now use the tuning
curve decoders with maximum likelihood
estimation as then this great curve over
here and you can see all three of these
naturally well and in fact the
unsupervised estimate
okay so here's unsupervised estimate
alpha and you can see that the answer
was estimate is actually closer to the
supervisors estimate of the internal
states of the brain okay
than it is to the measured head
direction so first of all it closely
matches head direction
ball of them do okay but moreover the
latent variable estimate is closer to
the estimate from the neural data of the
neural mental state than it is to the
measured head direction okay but just
not surprising because this brain area
first of all as the cognitive area so
there is expected to be a mismatch
between the measured head direction in
the internal states the animal may lose
track of exactly what its head Direction
is it has to construct this high
direction is a construct because there's
no sensory signal that's one dimensional
it tells you this is your head direction
it's based on all of these cues for the
animal it's just an internal estimate ok
so first of all it shouldn't be
surprising that theta had the internal
state slip relative to theta but the
unsupervised estimate is closer to the
internal States and moreover the
unsupervised estimate this latent
variable actually explains more spike
variance than the measured head
direction does okay so we can explain
more of the spiking data from our
unsupervised decoder then we can explain
using the measured head direction okay
so both of these things suggest that the
the latent variable is really tracking
the internal state of the brain rather
than than the external
actual head directions this is not cross
validated because we'll be not we're not
building a model we're not ever using
the actual head Direction data right to
build a model it's just
so you're just project so how are you so
we just predicting it by just you were
just reading out the value of the you
know this parametric flying at that
point and we get a number we just get
some one-dimensional decoding and then
all we do is just do about one global
rotation and global flip well no it's
just one thing right we just do one flip
one origin and one flip are just
unconstrained so that's that's all huh
yeah it's the best lip yeah the best the
best origin and the best and just choice
of two rotations because those are
arbitrary I mean those don't have any
meaning yes there's no meaning to them
you just you have to match it right it's
just two time series they're almost
exactly the same but they're just
shifted so you have to just get the
shift that's all they do
so yeah can't can't predict everything
because one you know what's the
bandwidth of it that direction right so
rotation of the head there's all kinds
of other variables that you're making an
assumption that head Direction is really
the output whereas it could be if you
measured a whole bunch of other external
variables that okay no actually right in
principle this circuit could be coding a
bunch of other variables but I've shown
you that's coding really a
one-dimensional ring variable so first
of all we know it's not coding ten
different variables or at least unlikely
to be unless it's in those small
dimensions that are like you know mix up
with the noise right so okay so I mean
there is a question know whether I you
know I can't tell you for sure that's
not coding some of these other variables
but it's not coding of them at large
variance I'll say okay secondly I should
have put up a number but like the the
fraction of spike variance captured is
huge it's like in the 90s Oh percent
okay so we're doing you know I mean
we're capturing so much spike variance
and what I'm saying is if you consider
two different just angular variables
which is an internal estimate of angular
variable or this latent variable
estimate versus the matter measured head
direction this one does better the
internal are unsupervised estimate of
head direction that's better than
measured head direction okay so that's
what I'm saying I think that is that's
neat it really is saying that you know
we're getting these cognitive States
rather than getting some
so I want to press on because I've got a
lot I want to cover and so and then we
can just see if some of the talks for
the questions for after I get through
some of this okay so now armed with this
you know decoded estimates of these
latent variables alpha now we can go
back and now regress neural firing onto
this latent variable and construct
tuning curves here in blue for
individual neurons and so we go ahead
and do that and behind the blue and
black are the tuning curves obtained in
the traditional supervised way based on
measured head Direction okay so the blue
ones are the completely unsupervised
tuning curves and the black ones are the
fully supervised tuning curves and you
can see that without using any
information about the external variable
we can recover almost you know down to
the minutest detail all of these Wiggles
in the tuning curve right so we get a
good reconstruction and once again fully
unsupervised no trial structure this we
do all of this with 50 200 milliseconds
decoding resolution and using only about
20 minutes of data from about 40 cells
okay I'm sorry
well these are all samples right I mean
that's all just you know okay you can
ask what is the difference right this is
an interesting thing to ask like what is
what are the small discrepancies in fact
you know traditionally if I looked at
this one I would assume that all of this
is just noise I would not even think
that these Wiggles are signal but the
fact that you know they're both sort of
doing the same thing you know sort of
seems to say that this really is the
angular variable and it's really you
know I'm covering that right but but
yeah I don't know I mean some of this is
like sampling noise and who knows what
the rest of it is the blue is the is the
unsupervised estimate and the black is a
supervised okay so now I want to ask you
know what can we say about the circuit
during sleep right so there are some
questions about well you know the
behavior is you know it's been you know
it's it's it's exploring this
two-dimensional space but in sleep
became pretty much do anything it wishes
to so now we look at you know their to
sleep States so let's first look at REM
sleep so let's look at the structure of
states during REM sleep and once again
we can do the you know topological data
analysis and we find again one prominent
feature in the data it's really this one
prominent ring you know at different
scales there is like you know some of
this like this is neck and so it looks
like there's independent rings but it's
not a torus which would have non-trivial
but two numbers which it doesn't have so
anyway so you can see now this is a co
embedding of the way
in blue states and the green the the
green and the RAM in green okay you can
see here by i2 that the red states
although a little bit noisier than the
waking States like pretty much right on
top of the waking manifold okay and this
is not just a two-dimensional projection
you can hook it in other projections etc
and it's pretty much right on top of it
and so once again we can do the same
parameter ization and extract an angular
variable from this and so okay so right
so so we can we can do that and now what
we're really interested in is
understanding okay so if the first okay
so let's see so what that means is that
even during REM sleep when the system is
unhinged from sensory input right it
could be mentally exploring sort of
anything the circuit really is
maintaining you know this this there's
this exact factor that it does during
waking I think that's really you know
pretty amazing REM sleep is the phase of
sleep characterized by you know rapid
eye movement
it's called rapid eye movement sleep
it's like this Li that's often called
dreaming sleep in humans but that's the
loose characterization I mean there's
actually like in hippocampus it looks
like there's something correlates of
dreaming awesome non REM sleep but it's
just like some it's just some scoring of
sleep into these two phases and they
have all this phenomenology associated
with each one so so I'm gonna talk about
REM and non-rem sleep this the right is
colorized by by this um by our latent
variable okay so this is a latent
variable coloring and this was just
waking in blue and green is red and
Klaus is not actually moving its head
asleep yes yes so it's not moving in
fact if that's uh muscles are paralyzed
oh really
that's right that's right okay so I
think it's pretty remarkable that the
manifold is like right on top of each
other so you don't have to assume that
the you know the states are the same in
waking and sleep in the circuit they
very much seem to be the same in waking
in at least REM sleep okay so now we're
interested yeah go ahead I was just
wondering if you look at the at the time
if you now reconstruct the green
direction yeah okay so um alright so now
let's look a little bit at the dynamics
of states during REM sleep okay so so
far told you more about you know states
but let's look at dynamic
so okay so first of all I'm showing you
let's look at blue first so these blue
manifolds of the wake manifold and then
I'm showing you one second long
trajectories on the wake manifold and
you can see this one second long
trajectories tend to just be pretty much
unidirectional right they start they
start in dark and go light and they just
kind of sweep around they sweep around
the ring right because because you're in
waking the animals kind of like
coherently moving right and it sort of
moves smoothly through angle and that's
what's going on over here and in fact
you can characterize the dynamics and
waking sleep of these trajectories by
looking at the autocorrelation of the
change in angle right like is the angle
changing in the same direction over time
versus delta T so you can look at that
and blue that's the autocorrelation of
of the change in time and in fact if you
look at also you can look at how the
squared deviation and angle verses per
unit time elapsed right per you know
interval of a lapse time during waking
it looks quadratic right so because if
you if you tend to move you know with
the you know in the same direction over
time then the squared deviation in your
angle will grow quadratically right but
linear as your time interval grows
linearly and that's exactly what you see
in waking but you're in sleep during REM
sleep what you see is that these
trajectories one second long
trajectories you see cover much less
space than over here and they seem to
kind of you know locally move around and
then double back on each other etc right
so qualitatively that's what's going on
so quantitatively we can look at you
know the histogram of change in angles
and and really angles change only
locally so right so this histogram is
really local right small changes in
angle in adjacent time steps and also if
you look at the autocorrelation of the
change in angles it decays very quickly
it's much faster than waking okay so
it's like less correlated and the
angular changes on the manifold I can
show you that all this is true at every
angle so it's sort of like a very kind
of homogeneous thing across all angles
and moreover if we look at the squared
change in angle per unit time then the
the curve actually looks very linear
over here okay so this is a signature
together with these signatures of you
know just a diffusion random you know
just a homogeneous diffusion process
along the ring okay so these states are
basically localized to this ring but
then they just randomly diffuse on it
okay and with the with just homogeneous
diffusion
and so now we have okay so now we can
say the states during REM sleep match
states exactly during waking and but the
dynamics are very different right and so
they're being coherent they're diffusive
okay so now we can ask what is the
source of the diffusivity on the
manifold right like what is the reason
why the states are diffusing in the
manifold what is causing that process
okay so now that gives us an opportunity
to actually apply some theory that you
know some theory for continued
subtractor networks as you all know this
like body of beautiful theoretical work
going back you know several decades on
green networks etc and recently you're
on Barak who many of you know who is
here in the program earlier and I did
some work on some theoretical work and
computing diffusion along continuous
attractor manifolds of arbitrary
dimension and so we have some analytical
results that allows us to compute the
expected diffusivity on this ring
network okay for matching the number of
neurons the estimate of the number of
neurons an order of magnitude on the
ring and then we match the you know sort
of the peak firing rates we assume that
the you know even if you've seen that
the peak firing rate is like you know 85
Hertz which is actually higher than the
data then you get a number of the
expected diffusivity which is the slope
of this curve that's about point 1
radians squared per second by contrast
in the data okay and the the source of
the diffusivity in this model is just
assuming that neurons condition and
their tuning curves are just firing on
Poisson spikes
okay so just intrinsic independent
iodine oiz per neuron okay so if that's
the source of diffusivity then we expect
something like this point one instead we
get diffusivity here that you can
clearly see is about one Radian squared
per second okay which is like ten times
larger in fact some of these datasets 10
to 40 times discrepancy okay so the data
the the states on the manifold are
diffusing about 10 to 40 times faster
then you would predict from internal
noise alone okay and so what is the
source of that huge diffusivity this is
a large excess diffusivity and so we
built a model of this network and and
and and and found that actually if the
inputs and also we can do this with the
analytics but if you assume that the
inputs the the the suspect there's an
input so okay so these um high
dimensional noise it's uncorrelated
across neurons
has a very small projection onto the 1d
manifold right so the diffusivity you
know for unit noise you know pretty
neuron is like very small because it's a
very small projection onto this manifold
but on the other hand this velocity
inputs presumably from the head from the
head velocity
you know estimation circuit that then
move the bump along the ring as the
animal is moving around the world right
so if we put in an input that's noisy in
the velocity input you know in this
channel along the ring okay that's so
the same order of magnitude as the
velocity and puts needed to move the
state around the ring to produce the
kinds of deflections that you would see
in waking right the match to the size of
the velocity inputs required to move the
bump around the ring the then then we
get a diffusivity that is you know that
can be matched to the diffusivity seen
in the in the in the data okay so in
other words it looks like basically the
states are moving around because of
noise and the input velocities channel
rather than noise within the circuit so
this kind of implies you this looks long
signing debate and you know in lots of
circuits is whether you know a lot of
noise is like input you know are
circuits like sort of input noise
limited or are they limited by noise
within intrinsically within the circuit
in this particular memory and
integration circuit it looks like it's
really like this input noise that's kind
of driving a lot of the drift rather
than the intrinsic noise so I think
that's that's something that's been
really satisfying to do something
quantitative like that sense we're in
different the combination of these two
resulting integrated level in some sense
for any strong in predictions on the
underlying connectivity in the circuit
or I mean you
maybe swamped by these input factors oh
you mean the diffusion observation I
think that I think the connectivity I
think I think the thing that really is
now constraining the connectivity is
really just this observation of these
low dimensional ring states right I mean
that really is telling us that like the
beautiful work from Genelia on like this
you know head Direction circuit in flies
there there was like a physical ring
here we're showing you that there is a
equally beautiful ring in the state
space right and that really tells you
the circuit is really this
one-dimensional effectively functionally
is this one-dimensional ring that's what
really constrains the circuitry I don't
think that the I don't think that the
diffusivity this Magnus this
quantitative measurement of diffusivity
is adding a further constraint on the
connectivity yeah I think that's all
like you know but it is saying that it's
noise dominated from the input intrinsic
yeah there's something that I think we
know what's happening in hippocampus
during sleep is that it's playing back
patterns of activity and kind of
occurred during day so when the animal
is experiencing going through a maze say
a circle and it goes through a bunch of
place fields nor us that there are
activated different locations yeah then
at night you get back the same sequence
but faster and if there's only the head
direction to is going no so exactly so
that is another reason why we were
motivated to look at this data set so
exactly so as Terry says hippocampus
shows it's beautiful like replay during
sleep you know signatures in the neural
activity and you know David shown
beautiful replay even just when the
animals resting etc but um you know
interestingly the head Direction circuit
didn't seem to show those replay events
so for example this will show you it's
not replay right because I mean well
it's not consistent with replay it's
really consistent with diffusion because
there's this very linear right
relationship in the Delta alpha squared
versus delta T if they were coherent
movements see the waking waking
trajectories because they tend to be
directionally coherent
you would expect some quadratic behavior
early on in the diffusivity curve we're
not seeing that right now on the other
end it could be that there's some small
coherent sweeps together with most of
the time doing diffusive behavior that
would be been dominated by the linear
part and we wouldn't see the quadratic
part so it's possible that varies
fraction of the time is doing something
coherent in rem but it doesn't seem to
be but let me get to the next slide and
I'll show you okay so oh and Michael
hasselmo had done some studies looking
at you know looking for a replay in
hydrogen circuit and not finding any and
that's an enduring mystery which is you
know why this high direction circuit
which is so intimately tied with the
navigation circuitry why does it not
seem to show replays when the other
circuits involved navigation like
hippocampus right that's what I'm going
to show you next
okay so all right so let's look at
states and dynamics during non-rem sleep
okay so um so okay so the first thing to
notice is the mustard color is are the
states and non-rem sleep and the blue
are the states in waking okay and here
you can see actually that this system
now does not possess a ring like
topology and in fact if we look at these
very number bar graphs these many bar
codes there is no ring feature president
and even visually we can have the luxury
for the slow dimensional data set to
inspect it visually and you can see
needed doesn't okay so this manifold
looks higher dimensional in fact it's
kind of flat so it's a quasi
two-dimensional you know modular the
fluffiness from the noise so you know
who can say how many real dimensions it
has but what we can do is we can now do
the same game but now we can
parameterize the two dimensions of the
manifold so we're going to give a
circular parameter ization again calling
it an angular variable alpha and we can
give it a radial parameterization okay
which is from the centroid of the
manifold out okay and so that's just
decode those two latent variables and so
we do that and you get this mustard
trace and in in gray what you're seeing
here is actually the the the what the
supervised tuning curve decoder from
waking applied to these states would
then give you okay so really this is
telling us that still lists this one of
the dimensions of this manifold really
still does represent this angular
variable as we think about it from
waking okay because those two things
match and that is it is it none where
I've seen that you get the plate replate
yeah yeah I'm gonna show you yeah hang
in there okay let's get to let's get to
that and then the second line is this
this radial direction and then we maybe
decode that when we decode this latent
vary
in the radial direction then we get
something that matches the gray curve
which is actually the population firing
rate okay so the second dimension is
really a modulation of the responses
these angular responses by some
fluctuations and finally okay like
overall global fluctuations in fire rate
and we can get you know the predicted
fire rate versus the actual and looks
pretty good okay so so these two
dimensions again we found like something
that is that matches the second
dimension so now let's do exactly what
teri wants to do which is look at the
dynamics on this manifold right because
that's that's the question now and so we
can do the old-fashioned thing which is
we can pretend we don't have this
manifold approach we're just going to
apply this tuning curve decoder right or
in other words just project all of these
states on to an angular variable this
one be an angle extract an angle and
then just look at the dynamics of that
angular variable so if we do that so
we're just looking at you know this also
this states on the manifold this two
dimensional manifold called Delta X but
it's also deviations Delta alpha which
isn't there angular decoding so when we
do that you know everything looks a bit
boring so actually if you look at if you
look at the system you know again the
the state's kind of change locally but
then if you look at the autocorrelation
of alpha dot this mustard curve you can
see that actually it has very it has
very little coherence apparently like
basically the autocorrelation drops to
zero faster than the waking data and if
you look at the the diffusivity curve
which is the variance or Delta alpha
squared versus delta T you know for
coherent trajectories again you would
expect to see something quadratic this
is the waking quadratic curve but it's
all squashed down because you know the
deviations are small during waking this
is the linear Ram response right this is
the pure diffusion curve which is linear
and now this looks like just diffusive
but with a very high diffusivity
coefficient which is what people assumed
is happening in rem on this in the
circuit but now if you look at a full
manifold the picture is a little bit
different so now if we look at actually
trajectories on the 2d manifold again
now you can look at these second long
trajectories and now you see these
beautiful sweeps in the two-dimensional
space
okay so there's these long coherent sort
of Arts in the two-dimensional space and
so when we look at that now we can
characterize some of the dynamics on
that so we find that you know if we look
at these trajectories also tend to
happen it's like fast times you know I
mean the
define let's just operationally let's
just talk about these trajectories of
things that have like very fast movement
on the manifold so we just put a cutoff
on speed on manifold and if you look at
those then you know these fast
trajectories that X dot greater than
this distribution tends to have very you
know more coherence because we're just
showing I'm plotting here the histogram
of changes an angle in adjacent parts of
the trajectory and this histogram is
peaked at lower changes and angles so
you know when it's moving fast it's also
moving changing direction less and at
low speeds it's changing direction more
and in fact so we also see these these
other trajectories which look more like
just staying in place so they're like
these sweeps staying in places that
corresponds to kind of this distribution
which is like a sweep this which is more
directionally cornering this which is
more staying in place and now when we
look at auto correlation on this whole
2d manifold then we find that it has
actually a longer coherence time then
even during waking so it's like
signatures of like a slower dynamics
during non-rem sleep than during waking
together with these coherent sweeps and
if we then plot the diffusivity curve
now you can see that you know for these
slow movements
they're pretty diffusive like this kind
of confined staying in place
trajectories are pretty diffusive and
linear over here but these faster
trajectories tend to be more
directionally coherent and therefore you
can also see this nice quadratic
signature in the diffusivity curve okay
so it really is kind of more cohesive or
coherent movement directionally okay and
finally the question is when do these
sweeps occur when are these high
coherence and high speed trajectories
happening it turns out that they happen
when there is a just a general increase
in LFP power in this area okay in
general and in fact we it also happens
when the LFP power increases
specifically in this part of the
frequency of the lfp which is in the
spindle ban and spindles in thalamus
tend to be coincident with twosome they
overlap with sharply ripples in
hippocampus okay so the thalamus doesn't
show sharp wave ripples it shows these
spindles which tend to be correlated and
sharp wave ripples are when these replay
events seem to happen during REM sleep
in in hippocampus so that is a bit
suggestive we wonder whether these
smooth sweeps in head Direction the high
direction system have something to do
with some of these
these events that happens a kiss at a
sharp wave here at the upper right okay
so this thing here is just a general
increase in in LFP so what I'm showing
you here this is these are this this is
like a spike-triggered average but like
an event triggered average this is like
when is there like this high velocity
trajectory okay and then we plot the you
know the high velocity trajectory
triggered lfp power absolute power and
you see that actually is a spike in the
LFP power and here when of the low
velocity trajectories are happening when
there's a dip in the overall and the
fifth power and this is showing the
breakdown by frequency of the lfp and so
this is showing you that actually the
correlation between the amplitude of the
lfp and these you know these are this
lfp I believe is measured within the
ballast so yeah that's what what the
implication for the happen in two
dimensions I don't think that you need
it but I'm just saying that you know
what's going on here the two dimensional
manifold so you know the second
dimension of this from the radio so it
turns out that what you can think of you
can think about this as this angular
variable and then amplitude modulation
sort of filling in the ring to make it a
disc it's kind of like the ring and all
scaled versions of the ring going down
to the origin and so these are really
like the amplitude modulation that are
characteristic of slow wave sleep right
it's like you know this it's it's like
in cortex we call these on and off
States and here in in and really it's a
bit of a misnomer because he's on an off
States rather than just being binary
like high amplitude low amplitude are
really some grated continuum right it
really is some like more smooth
amplitude modulation and that's really
what we're seeing here and that's what
fills in the two dimensions I don't know
why I mean I just all we know is that
the manifold looks two-dimensional and
on the two dimensional manifold there
are these smooth features well the
reason you didn't see it so the question
is why do you see the smooth sweeps in
2d but not in 1d and it's because you
know these smooth sweeps you know
sometimes will cross the origin like
here's an example of a smooth sweep
that's passing through the midline or
the centroid and so even though it's
smooth and 2d if you can start the
projections onto 1d you can see how
quickly
you know the projections here can very
quickly jump from like at this point you
can maybe do a projection here but then
like just a little bit away I should
just touch it by hand so basically if
you are here you might project at this
point on the manifold because that's the
closest but if you're here you might
project to this point on the manifold so
it looks jumpy but it's artefactual it
really isn't it's just like by taking a
smooth 2d trajectory you're projecting
it on to one dimension so they're all
these like sort of discontinuities in
the in the readout so it's just the
decoding issue right it's just that if
you're decoding directly onto the
angular variable it looks jumpy though
it is it just wondering what is telling
us about this I don't know that's I mean
I would love to talk about it yeah yeah
question but already you can discover
that these things exist right which is
pretty clear yeah this is pure wedding
and I sleep it's like pure wedding okay
all of this actually happens in a very
high dimensional space and the distance
is so deceptive so we just don't have a
good intuition what this is well no it's
happening on the manifold right I mean
the manifold itself yeah exactly exactly
so my eyes yeah because of the geometry
that's right not what's close to one we
don't know exactly that's exactly right
right David but just think he's just
pointing out that you know again this is
for a pure viewing pleasure but you know
it's flattened you know but but we're
not using the you know the really
flattened stuff right we just sort of
trying to yeah to do this yeah but then
you question where does the third
dimension moving encoded oh yeah I mean
well you could ask whether it is encoded
presumably it is and yeah I'm this
beautiful work in bats from the Olin
auskey lab showing that there is
actually a third dimension in the head
direction in their head direction
circuits I don't think that people have
found that I'm sorry
no after the fact whether the hand
yes you're right we could colorize so I
think what you're suggesting andreas and
we're doing this is we could then you
could say well look it's one-dimensional
ring but it could be that there's a
small low variance dimension along in
the ring itself right like there's a
cloud right I mean there has some
thickness and the question is is all of
the thickness noise or is there like a
little bit of modulation first of all we
can rule out that it's a big modulation
right there is not like an extensive
dimension that's of the same size
encoding the third dimension that is
clear from the from from the data but
it's true that it could be a small
modulation based on so we should we can
just recolor eyes apparently then it
wouldn't be like to provide direction
data come from well turns out that there
are LEDs on the mouse head to LEDs that
give you a vector right right it doesn't
tell you anything about 3d yeah yeah I
know but I guess no but you know they
could I guess it's like I mean if you
had three LED points you could compute
that after we do cosine right okay and I
got a whole sum of data from Bruce
McNaughton that actually had four LEDs
yeah
tilt information and always direction
and indeed we were able to decode the
third dimension and actually something
that we pulled out was well where is the
intro for the rap where is the you know
the where's the head orientation where
is where in the head is it is it in the
middle of a head is it in the snout
turns out it's it's in front of the rep
it's not actually in the rap it's a
little bit in front a little above the
stuff that deaths that's what it's
coding for the third dimension we're up
and down yeah so anyway yeah so if we
had like if we had a you know a
measurement of the of the other
dimension we could see it but again so
the point is that it's not an extensive
it's not a large dimension in in the in
the coding space right and so you know
we could I would I would argue that by
you know one thing that we could do is
we could try to quantify the the noise
cloud size and and the variability and
the responses and determine you know is
there anything beyond right yeah is
there any information in that small
dimension okay and that's that's
basically I think the question that we
have to ask okay so um now I want to do
I have I mean there was a lot of
questions along the way so should I keep
going or should I just basically stop
huh ten more minutes yeah I mean I guess
I should ask you right so yeah ten more
minutes okay great so then um okay so
then the question is so I showed you
mostly thalamic data but this high
direction tuning exists also in this
circular area called Pacific ulam and I
by the way I'll just say now that you
know I'm only going to end up talking
about the data decoding part I guess I'm
not going to be talking about you know
the second part which was the more
modeling of you know how the brain has
low dimensional how to extract low
dimensional variables or might my
training networks so another day or just
we could talk in breaks or something
like that
so okay so I want to tell you that about
what data look like in this area post
cibecue ylim rather than in the thalamus
in idiot okay so it turns out that the
the data of the head Direction data in
post cibecue lemn is higher dimensional
significantly higher dimensional and so
it's it's difficult in in this data to
really you know and and it looks compact
there's no ring structure in it and so
I'm just showing you a plot the point
cloud of the posts of the given data and
here it's colorized by the same okay so
what we can do here is we can colorize
it in a couple of ways one thing we can
do is we can colorize it by constructing
tuning curves in the supervised way and
then colorizing it another way that we
can do it is we can co embed the data
here jointly with so this is the
thalamic data this is the post cibecue
leur data we can Co embed it with
together the circular in the lamech data
and then do the unsupervised decoding
with it and then extract the
unsupervised this latent variable and
then colorize base
variable and that's what you're seeing
here okay so this is the colorization of
the post cibecue Lamanna fold by the
latent variable and you can see that
there is a real sense in which the post
the bicular data really does encode
angle because this is continuous sort of
movement as you go along this manifold
in this dimension okay even though it's
higher dimensional so so there is that
there is some angular coding okay and in
fact also we know that the angular
information present because when we go
in bed and then we decode then the
quality of the decoding is better okay
so those two things tell us that post
the bycula does have angular data and
that's something that you can know from
the physiology and supervised decoding
approaches that it does okay so if we
look at this is post cibecue l'm in
waking okay and for comparison this is
the thalamic nucleus in waking you can
see they're quite different these are
you know local dimensionality estimates
which are you know just very ballpark
estimates tell us that you know in
waking and the lamina in thalamus it's
like order one or two the the local
dimension whereas here in post the
bycula mand gives us a number that's
higher whereas thalamus has a ring
structure post the bycula me you know
it's not during waking but one thing
that's really interesting then is you
can ask what is this post the bicular
response and coding like what are the
other things that it's encoding since
it's high dimensional it turns out that
if you look at this post cibecue limb
response and you plot the states in
waking versus REM okay they're actually
linearly separable they're they're just
separate blogs okay they're just
separate and this contrast that with the
thalamic response where those two
responses lay right on top of each other
okay so so in one area they're linearly
separable and the other area the right
on top of each other wait
oh that's just us doing we just
constructing the separatrix between the
two and then here this is post cibecue
l'm in waking versus post cibecue l'm in
non-rem and you can see once again
they're just linearly separable from one
another these two manifolds okay and we
can do that again also for ram versus
non ram and those two are also linearly
separable from one another so so first
of all it looks like the post cibecue
ylim is constructing some kind of very
explicit or at least you know explicit
in the sense of linearly separable
decoding of the behavioral State which
is the sleep or waking
States and uh okay so it's um you know
so and it must be like because it's how
high dimensional it must also be
encoding perhaps some other variables
and we find that actually we can
colorize then the the manifold by speed
okay just the absolute speed and we find
this nice gradient in post cibecue and
based on speed
okay along the manifold and there's a
few other variables we don't actually
see coding for spatial location in any
clear way along the manifold so we can
just colorize a manifold according to
all of these things and figure out okay
so now this encoding of these two
different these different states like
you can actually build oops sorry
we can build a decoder that separates
wake and RAM wake and slow wave and RAM
and slow wave or non RAM and using the
manifold technique we can get a decoding
accuracy of 94 99 92% and it's not
simply a separation by firing rate it's
not simply that the post cibecue limb
states and waking are high rate whereas
the post cibecue ylim states in rem are
lower rate because when we construct
these decoders based on just rate okay
then we achieve much lower percentage
things so it's not simply a rate
modulation there really is some other
nonlinear transformation that's taking
these you know states that are not
linearly decodable in the thalamus and
making them linearly separable in the in
the in the post the big um okay so so it
certainly does that it's up it does some
separation and then you know it leads to
you know all this leads to a bunch of
questions so just to summarize then what
i've told you about
it's possible to do direct visualization
of low dimensional state space ring in
the mammalian head rection circuit okay
and this is i think beautiful in the
same way that seeing a physical ring in
the insect high direction circuit was
really a revelation i was equally
surprised to see it as such a nice ring
in the in the in the mammalian head
direction okay can consistent with you
know decades of theory i think also it's
a proof of concept of accurate
unsupervised decoding of internal
cognitive states we can understand
circuit dynamics during non vague States
and across brain regions without the
assumption that the states equal to wake
states and then finally we can get a
quantitative and not just qualitative
understanding of REM diffusion and
that helps us understand that the
representations and memory and
integration of angle are probably
limited by sensory noise rather than by
internal noise okay and moreover
hopefully these quantitative measures of
diffusivity based on internal noise the
question is whether in different
neuropathology coal States whether you
know the circuits are wired less well
and whether there's diffusivity that's
in excess of that seen in healthy brains
and so there's some evidence that in
certain brain disorders like autism they
can be more diffusivity of or just noise
and in circuits and so I'm curious to
look over there and yeah and so so this
is sort of where you know we think we
can go and and then you know as I said
they're also like it seems like this
moment for manifold decoding is right
because we've got finally large data
sets something we didn't have the luxury
to have before larger the data set if
the manifold dimension remains fixed is
going to improve the signal-to-noise
ratio so just improve our ability to do
higher time resolution you know a higher
dimensional manifold decoding etc right
all that stuff will will improve and so
and I of groups like I mentioned I'm
working on these approaches so I think
it's an exciting time so I'll stop there
and take any questions that I ignore it
earlier put up Linkous my
acknowledgments like how many more
dimensions it are they needed to and for
the first lips victim and and
yeah so the number is yeah okay so these
numbers again like you know so this
dimensionality estimates are corrupted a
bit by the noise and the data right
because you've got like n-dimensional
noise on top of whatever the low
dimensional manifold is so in this plot
that I'd shown you earlier okay I'll
just pull that out right here here's a
plot of the kind of dimension local
correlation dimensions that we can
extract it as many different measures so
we can apply different measures but the
correlation dimension tells us that in
waking there's like about a 2 2 times
discrepancy in dimension so whatever
what we get in the I think these
comparative estimates are sound like we
can say you know you can certainly trust
the order and you can trust like some
rough
you know if scaling but you can't
necessarily take that number and say
it's really four-dimensional it's
probably like maybe three or something
like that now in rem we get numbers like
you know slightly higher because there's
more noise in the REM State over here
over the correlation dimension and again
we get something like three or four year
and then in in non-rem okay both of them
get you know how you dimensional and and
estimate of it so again nice Christmas
is the topological approach sort of is
it most useful if you have a
one-dimensional or two-dimensional
structure logical approach is tells you
about you know the connectedness of the
manifolds like basically tells you more
about the global properties the manifold
like you know is it like a torus is it a
ring is it like two connected linked
tourists you know whatever like you know
about like you know the the holiness of
the structure right are the holes in it
and it's more this global features and
then the these correlation dimensions
tell you locally like right even if you
have a ring you could have a ring where
locally you know part of the Ring the is
like kind of flat like a ribbon and
other parts where it gets really narrow
like really like a line right
so these correlation dimension
approaches should tell you that you know
whether it's kind of more ribbon like or
more line like in those places like for
example a topological measure wouldn't
tell the difference between a sheet and
a line so you don't have a ring for both
the beginning yeah yeah Oh Griffin yeah
yeah it's really highly non-trivial and
very surprising that you find this
beautiful ring it is I think so too I
think it's very non-trivial yeah first
of all where exactly is this head
Direction system it wasn't
representative these samples in the data
so do they look for head Direction cells
or this list represented
yeah that's a good question so um so
this is a TN okay and there's three
circuits that have head direction this
lmn lateral mm le mammillary nucleus and
then a TN and then post the bycula right
oh and also like of course you know even
the grid cell circuit system and the
deeper layers has hydrogen tuning so um
so this is a TN oh I think to some
extent they do listen for head Direction
tuning but then they pick up you know
these are like multi they pick up
multiple units on the same tetrode we
did no cell selection whatsoever we did
not right because this is supposed to be
on supervised method we don't select any
cells we just take all the data that
they get on their electrodes you know
that are you know then they can isolate
a single units and throw them in and as
you could see in some of these tuning
curves that we reconstructed you know
some of the cells really just don't have
narrow tuning and some of them have very
narrow tuning like like over here so you
can see this right like you know if we
were doing selection for head Direction
tuning we would have kicked that one out
but we didn't right and we would have
probably thrown that one out and that
one out and that one out but we just
throw them all give you a ring well it
doesn't give you a nice ring you know in
some cases like yeah it doesn't give you
a nice ring it looks you know much and
and it it you know connect some of the
parts right there's no reason why PCA
should give you a nice ring if it really
is a super nonlinear curve that's
stretching along all the axes right
because then there's no linear low
dimensional they're not that narrow
exactly and that's why and that's why
PCA can kind of work but it's much much
worse and we've we have some PC applauds
to that just terrible with on it then I
can switch the last way to show the
dimensionality estimates yeah this one
here oops this one here these two
features yeah did you check for yeah we
did yeah so it's not a okay good good
question I can show you why we get that
and and and everyone can see why that is
and that helps give some insight here we
did look at Betty - and there's no Betty
- and that one
let me let me find you good oh let's
just look at this example right so so
this one will give us two rings at some
radius because you can see that there's
a there's a constriction here in the
ring and so at a certain radius
you know this hole will be filled this
this will be filled in to be a line okay
so it looked like one ring and another
ring so you'll get so then you'll get to
yeah yeah yeah so that's right so you
can see here you get a ring and another
you know kind of persistent ring you can
see that so that's why you get multiple
ones because of all of this stuff but
then you know but there made me look at
Betty too there isn't a Betty too so
it's not a Taurus right so we know that
from that right so it's just another
data set yeah one can you we can we can
look at that one together so we've got
the the plot throughout those well I
think thank you for the discussions we
can continue in tournaments and
[Applause]